- Олена Зеркаль, заступниця глави МЗС України.
Чи Європа і Росія забули про Україну?
- Я так не думаю. Насправді Європа забула
про війну, про наслідки війни та незахищеність через це.
- Це стосується безпеки чи бізнесу?
- Для нас це - справа безпеки. Звісно,
це не стосується доходів. Йдеться про гарантії
нашої безпеки та трубопровід, який ми маємо.
Це певна гарантія для нас.
- Чому Трамп сказав, що Німеччина
стане заручницею російських енергоресурсів?
- Тому що Німеччина буде отримувати
понад 80% російського газу.
- Нині вона отримує 60% із Норвегії, Нідерландів,
власного виробництва. Я маю на увазі,
це доволі багато.
- Так, і це буде монополізація, а не диверсифікація.
- Чому монополізація?
- Тому що збільшиться кількість російського газу
в Німеччині і держави Центрально-Східної Європи
втратять свою роль як транзитні країни.
- Ви думаєте, що Трамп на вашому боці?
- Я думаю, що Трамп переслідує власні інтереси.
Але він точно розуміє, що Росія - це загроза.
- Його інтерес у тому, що він хоче продавати
зріджений газ у Європу, який значно дорожчий.
- Звісно, і це стосується бізнесу, а ми говоримо про безпеку.
- Втрати від транзиту, яких ви можете зазнати
через "Північний потік-2", - що вони означають
для вашої економіки - економіки, яка і так
зазнає втрат через конфлікт?
- Це, власне, те, що ми витрачаємо на нашу армію.
І це те, як ми захищаємо свою країну від Росії
без підтримки країн НАТО й американських баз
на нашій території.
- Тож Україні треба подумати, що робити далі.
- Звісно, нам потрібна підтримка інших країн,
інших союзників, щоб захиститися.
- Ви стурбовані безпекою ФРН? Як питання безпеки
Німеччини впливає на Україну?
- У Німеччини є військові бази і вона захищена
5-ю статтею договору Альянсу. А ми - ні.
Тож, звісно, ми менш захищені.
- Який гарантований об’єм транзиту газу
через територію України ви б хотіли бачити
чи потрібен, щоб не виступати проти "Північного потоку-2"?
- Не думаю, що ми віримо в якісь гарантії,
особливо з боку Росії.
Є Будапештський меморандум.
І що сталося з нами?
Хто зараз допомагає нам захищатися? Ніхто.
Власне, ми покладаємося на певну підтримку
з боку Німеччини, щоб встановити мир в Україні.
Але ми точно не віримо в жодні угоди  з росіянами.
- Але подивіться, як багато компаній
за цим проектом: німецькі, французькі.
Це величезні європейські зусилля і, звісно,
не спрямовані проти України.
- Звісно, це економічно життєздатний проект,
тому що європейське законодавство
не застосовується щодо нього. Вони можуть
заробляти гроші без жодних правил. При цьому
ми прагнемо повністю застосовувати
європейське законодавство в Україні
і діяти відповідно до нього.
- І ще одне. Що б ви хотіли побачити у 2019-му,
коли цей проект фактично завершать?
Це один із найбільш суперечливих проектів у світі,
але схоже, що робота над ним просуватиметься.
- Ми все ще покладаємося на застосування правил
і правових режимів щодо усіх проектів,
зокрема й "Північного потоку-2". І ми думаємо,
що це - шлях уперед без санкцій,
у нормальних правових рамках, які можна
застосовувати для всіх гравців на ринку.
- Ви б підтримали американські санкції проти німецьких компаній?
- Я б підтримала застосування директиви ЄС
для ринку газу щодо "Північного потоку-2".
- Дякую, що прийшли. Було приємно поспілкуватися.
- І мені так само.